Jeremy Renner may no longer have his own app,
but hey, now he has his own show! "Hawkeye" on
Disney+ is very fun, but after the first two
episodes, we have questions. Like, what's up
with Kate Bishop's mom's fiance's uncle's
death? And who's a good boy? Let's explore!
“Hawkeye” Episode 1 starts off
with a bang — or hundreds of them,
you could say — as we’re transported back
in time to the Battle of New York from the
original “Avengers” film. After we get a
brief glimpse into the shaky marriage of
young Kate Bishop’s parents Eleanor and Derek
Bishop, their swanky penthouse starts shaking
and eventually crumbling as the Chitauri
decimate the buildings of New York.
A young Kate is on her own in the penthouse
as she gets separated from her parents,
and a Chitarui almost takes her out, but we
see that an arrow from Hawkeye takes down
the small alien ship before it claims her. Kate
spots Hawkeye on the roof of a nearby building,
identifying her savior, who then leaps
from the building and shoots a grapple
arrow — a throwback to a famous
Clint moment from “The Avengers.”
It’s at this moment that Kate becomes inspired,
thanks to the heroic efforts of Hawkeye on that
roof. He saved her life, and she admits to her
mom at her father’s funeral that she wants a bow
and arrow. Thanks to Hawkeye’s heroism that day in
New York, Kate takes up archery and other skills,
including karate and fencing. Without Clint,
there would be no Kate Bishop in the MCU.
One of the goals of Episode 1 of “Hawkeye”
is to explain to the viewer what’s going on
with Clint since we last saw him in “Avengers:
Endgame.” It’s been more than two years since
his last MCU scene as he attended Tony Stark’s
funeral, but he was reunited with his family.
He is still with his kids as “Hawkeye” kicks
off, as we see the foursome attend “Rogers:
The Musical” without mom. Watching the
silly musical turns out to be slightly
triggering for Clint, who clearly is
annoyed at the nonsense of it all.
"Honey, I know what happens. I was there. You
know who wasn't there? It's that guy. Ant-Man."
He’s mostly in his feelings about
the loss of his best friend Natasha,
as we see his mind wander after the musical
version Natasha starts cart-wheeling around.
It’s here that he takes a break
and leaves to go to the restroom,
and we also see him fumble with his
hearing aid. It turns out Clint has
suffered some severe hearing loss in his left
ear thanks to his adventures with the Avengers.
It looks like Clint is making up for lost
time with his kids and is spending the days
leading up to Christmas with them. Laura is
off at their farmhouse and explains their
separation by suggesting this is supposed
to be Clint’s one-on-one time with his kids.
Of course, Clint is pulled away from
his family after spotting Kate on TV
in the Ronin suit from “Avengers: Endgame.”
We’re introduced to two villains in
the first episode of “Hawkeye.” One
is the Tracksuit Mafia, who are truly
living up to their Marvel Comics hype.
We don’t really get a sense of who
they are and why they’re so angry,
but we do know that they had run-ins with Ronin
when he was on his killing rampage after The Snap.
They chase down Kate after she fumbles their
heist of the secret black market auction,
but Clint comes to save the day after he
sees his Ronin suit back on the streets of
New York. Kate snatched it during the auction
chaos while Jack made off with Ronin’s sword.
Speaking of Jack, this is another
villain we need to keep our eye on.
He has suspiciously wooed Kate’s widow mother,
and the pair are now engaged. He loves swords,
which is no surprise given Jack is pulled directly
from the Marvel Comics character Jacques Duquesne,
aka Swordsman. A former mentor and teacher
of Clint, Jaques has no connection with
Kate Bishop in the comics, so this is an
interesting twist “Hawkeye” is giving us.
While we don’t know what Jack is up to in Episode
1, his creepiness alone lets us know he is up to
no good. It’s already suspected that he’s
involved in the death of his uncle Armand,
and there's some talk at the
auction of a sizable inheritance.
While Episode 1 served as an
introduction to Kate, her mother Eleanor,
Jack, the Tracksuit Mafia — oh, and we can’t
forget Lucky the Pizza Dog! — it gave us a
good idea of where “Hawkeye” is going and
themes that will be carried throughout.
Clint is clearly still dealing with the grief
of losing Natasha, while he also seems to be
trying to cover up his past as Ronin. He still
has enemies from his days as the vigilante,
and they’re coming back to haunt him
thanks to his number one fan, Kate.
Kate, a vigilante in her own right, is now
working to uncover the mystery of her future
step-dad and the murder of Armand III (who, in
the comics, is actually Jack’s father). She’s
become the target of the Tracksuit Mafia, who
clearly are not the men in charge. We suspect
Kate and Clint will find out they somehow
have a connection to one another, especially
given how all these characters intertwine in
the comics. And then there's the lingering
mystery of that watch, which is very important
to the Tracksuit Mafia for some unknown reason.
"We have 90 seconds to find the
watch. Everything else is secondary."
Episode 2 picks up immediately after Episode
1, as Clint Barton is pulling the Ronin mask
off of Kate Bishop in an alley. Clint is
keen on getting his suit back from Kate,
so they head to her apartment
to hide out for a moment.
While still in shock that she’s with the real
Hawkeye, Kate changes and hands the suit over
to Clint. Unfortunately, those pesky Tracksuit
Mafia members have tracked them down and start
throwing Molotov cocktails through her apartment
window. The apartment eventually catches fire,
causing the duo to abandon the Ronin suit,
and now Kate and Clint are on the run.
Once the Tracksuit Mafia sets
Kate’s apartment on fire,
the duo has to bolt and head somewhere safe.
Kate decides to go to her aunt’s apartment,
since she's out of town. Clint forces Kate to
hide out there while he heads back to retrieve
the suit. He finds out one of the firemen
stole it, which is just another unnecessary
obstacle for Clint to overcome. He comes back
to visit Kate and helps her patch up a wound,
and we get a peek at how Clint might
become a father figure to his new friend.
The following day, Clint has to ditch
his kids as he sends them off to be
with their very understanding mom. He
revisits Kate back at their hideout,
and then they go their separate ways
but not before exchanging phone numbers.
Clint thinks this is the last time he’ll see Kate
and begs her only to call if she has an emergency.
It’s now Clint’s mission to retrieve the Ronin
suit and figure out why the Tracksuit Mafia is
stirring up trouble yet again. He travels to a
live-action role-play event to find his suit,
where he suspects the thieving
firefighter will be wearing it.
Clint must sign up and participate in
the event to get to the firefighter,
which turns into one of the best
slow-motion bits ever to be seen in the MCU,
as Clint (fake) slices and dices
some hilarious adversaries. After
a duel with the thief, Clint is finally
in possession of the Ronin suit again.
Back at Kate’s mom’s penthouse, Jack is back
doing very Jack things. He continues to fool
Kate’s mom while not fooling his soon-to-be
daughter-in-law, but he also doesn’t seem to care.
Kate ends up challenging him to a fencing match,
where he pretends to be the lesser competitor.
As Kate yells at Jack to stop letting
her win, she eventually tricks him into
showing off his true talent and uses this
as a way to prove he’s some kind of liar.
"Sorry for scaring you into telling the truth."
Obviously Jack is a liar, but we’re still
not sure what his true intentions are.
He's still in possession of the Ronin
sword, but it's unclear what his plan is.
After his fencing match with Kate, he offers her
a butterscotch, one which matches those in a bowl
at Armand's house from Episode 1. This appears to
be enough proof for Kate that Jack killed Armand,
but in reality, all it suggests is that
Jack has been to his Uncle’s house before.
Jack's involvement with his uncle's death is
still unclear, but things don't look good.
While Kate is having some family fun, Clint sets
himself up to be kidnapped by the Tracksuit Mafia.
He tells his wife on the phone that he’s doing
a catch and release, which Laura points out is
“Classic Nat.” After luring the goons to
him, Clint is taken to a secret location,
where he continues to tell the gangsters
he wants to talk to the person in charge.
After realizing Clint’s in trouble, Kate comes
to help after tracking his location but falls
through the roof of the building and causes
a mess instead. As Kate and Clint are tied
up by the gang, one of the mafia members goes
into a speaker-filled room to get the boss.
As the bass in the background booms, we
get our first look at Maya Lopez, aka Echo.
It’s the briefest of glimpses as the screen cuts
to credits after we see her face, but it promises
us an even bigger episode for next week. Echo,
who already has her own series coming to Disney+,
is a deaf hero who is mainly known for her
role in the “Daredevil” comics. The adoptive
daughter of Kingpin, Echo’s appearance
in “Hawkeye” might hint that we could
be getting a second go-round with Wilson
Fisk from the Netflix “Daredevil” series.
Or the MCU could remix her origin the way
it's done with plenty of other heroes.
While it looks like Echo is the villain
now, we can almost guarantee she won’t
be. There is either a bigger threat we
haven’t met, or Jack truly is the big bad.
The biggest takeaway from “Hawkeye”
Episode 2? Still no Yelena Belova
from "Black Widow," as promised, but we
expect she's right around the corner.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Hawkeye"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.